salut nous sommes donc dimanche matin et
hier soir c'était l'anniversaire de
pierre cros et 30 ans ainsi que l'a fait
pour son million d'abonnés autant dire
qu'on n'est pas entré très tôt et que ce
petit levé ce matin pour faire la vidéo
a été le plus du hand élevé de l'année
mais rassurez vous la vidéo
hier donc j'ai plus qu'à la tournée à la
montée à la mettre en ligne pour qu'elle
sorte à 11 heures il égalait 10h02 c'est
jouable avec une magnifique vue sur sur
ma tasse montagnarde
cette semaine on a un petit peu changé
le rythme des vidéos pour faire une
semaine spéciale sur les
micro-expressions il existe cette micro
expressions principal majeur est
universelle et on les a détaillées tout
une par une cette semaine la colère le
dégoût le mépris la surprise la joie la
peur mais ça fait aussi ça c'est
pourquoi je vous propose de clôturer
cette semaine en parlant de la tristesse
la tristesse est liée à une douleur
émotionnelle que ce soit la vôtre c'est
à dire vous vous êtes triste
personnellement de quelque chose ou
qu'elle soit liée à un aspect plus
empathique c'est-à-dire il ya un
événement qui vous affecte ou la
tristesse de quelqu'un d'autre qui vous
affecte avant de vous donner la liste
des muscles principaux rentrer en marche
dans le micro expressions je vous
rappelle qu'une micro expressions une
combinaison complète c'est une
association de plusieurs muscles qui se
met en marche en même temps est un des
signes de la tristesse n'est pas
forcément un muscle qui se met en marche
ou pas et c'est quelque chose de dur à
expliquer avec les mots c'est quand les
yeux regarde un peu le lointain comme si
les yeux se perdent et on dit la
personne regarde du vide le regard
semble un petit peu ailleurs sinon au
niveau des muscles nous avons la
commissure des lèvres le coin des lèvres
qui descend légèrement ne vous attendez
pas forcément avoir toujours dieu je
pense que ma tête est magnifique comme
dans tout les micro-expressions c'est
plus léger l'intérieur des sourcils qui
remonte légèrement un petit peu comme
dans la peur et contrairement à la peur
c'est les paupières supérieures qui vont
se baisser un petit peu dans la peur à
ceux relève serré sun micro expressions
qu'on peut cacher avec plus ou moins de
succès et dans certains cas il arrive
qu'il y ait une petite dilatation des
narines
oui des narines comme ça avec des trucs
qui coule non ça c'est dégueulasse
d'ailleurs la personne pleurs j'ai pas
trouvé dans mes visionnage récent
d'exemples concrets à pouvoir isoler et
vous insérez j'en ai cherchés pas mal je
pense qu'il faudrait plus de temps c'est
le genre de choses que je pourrais plus
faire plus facilement l'année prochaine
quand on sortira du rythme d'une vidéo
par jour mais je pense qu'on peut en
voir souvent dans les émissions de
télé-réalité vu les tensions qui s'y
passe les espèces de petites trahisons
qui a les personnes qui sont éliminés ou
pas je pense qu'on doit en voir assez
régulièrement les micro-expressions de
tristesse vous vous demandez pourquoi si
je pressens qu'il y en a là dedans je
n'ai pas cherché et bien excuser moi de
m sauvé de quelques heures de visionnage
de télé réalité mais n'hésitez pas vous
pouvez le faire vous aussi vous voulez
voici quand même une illustration très
probante avec tous les muscles en
fonction ça c'est vraiment vous avez
tout sur cette photo il faut également
savoir que la peur est souvent précédé
ou accompagné de signes d'anxiété de
stress
j'en avais déjà parlé dans les trois
vidéos que je vous ai faite sur le
mensonge
ce qui me fait rebondir dans les récents
commentaires de cette semaine vous
m'avez souvent demandé des vidéos sur le
mensonge ou sur d'autres sujets des
vidéos qui ont déjà été faits il ya déjà
3 111 vidéo sur la chaîne au moment
je vous parle penser à checker dans les
playlists j'ai essayé de catégoriser il
ya souvent la vidéo vous cherchez des
idées m sur les questions sur pourquoi
la vidéo avec une numérotée ou qu'est ce
que tu feras l'année prochaine où c'est
quoi la musique que tu utilises c'est
quoi le tee shirt que tu portes quels
sont tes date de spectacle en général
vous trouvez la réponse dans la
description tout simplement je vous
avoue que c'est très frustrant de lire
un commentaire sur une info que j'ai mis
dans la description le jour-même exprès
pour que les gens se posent pas la
question
et tant qu'on est à parler de ce sujet
là dans les vidéos du style la faq ou la
vidéo spéciale pour les cent mille
abonnés
j'ai répondu à beaucoup de question que
vous me posez aussi régulièrement et je
ne réponds pas à ces questions dans les
commentaires puisque ça déjà été
répandues je préfère privilégier des
choses qu'on m'a pas déjà demandé
j'espère vraiment qu avoir pris tant
chaque jour de la semaine de parler
d'une micro expressions c'était un truc
que vous m'avez beaucoup demandé cette
année j'espère que ça ça vous aura plu
ça m'a beaucoup plu de le faire merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo qui
a conçu la semaine prochaine aussi pour
qu'on refasse des choses différentes
j'ai plein de sujets à vous parler j'ai
des gens à mentaliser n'oubliez pas
avant de partir de liker cette vidéo
c'est important si vous pensez oublier
ben n'oubliez pas les fêtes le temps
qu'on est sur une vidéo comme ça un peu
blabla merci à tous ceux qui me suivent
ponctuellement ou à fond en regardant
toutes les vidéos merci à ceux qui
partagent les vidéos ça c'est grâce à
vous que la chaîne comme ça elle elle
peut continuer à se faire connaître
merci particulier à ceux qui sous titre
les vidéos qui le rendent accessibles
aux malentendants
bravo et si vous personnellement vous
n'êtes pas encore abonné à la chaîne
d'immortal blog n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner en cliquant ici ou par ici ou
sous la vidéo parce que le mental box
est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez vous demain à 17h charme